si l'église du sacré-coeur détruite par
le séisme de 2010 est encore en
reconstruction
la messe est dite juste à côté
l'assassinât du président joël moïse est
dans tous les esprits
le prêtre offre la consolation d'une
présence divine il manque la cible
[Musique]
ils portent aux jo c'est pas évident
d'avoir de l'espoir d'un avenir meilleur
pour une population pourtant habitués
aux plus grande violence
aujourd'hui indignés stupéfié par cet
acte barbare pour bouleverser
il dit que c'est un commentaire est ce
qu'on peut dire c'est pas possible le
président nous a personne personne ne
sait rien où était la sécurité
totalement absente nous dit cette
voisine du président parce que de notre
salon justement on voit moi je vois la
toiture de chez le président de la
république et tout de suite on s'est dit
oui parce qu'on s'est dit ça doit être
un attentat la nuit du 7 juillet est
réveillé par la fusillade
depuis 2018 il y a deux guérite au
dessus de la résidence
moi je vais vous dire que ça fait très
longtemps que je n'ai pas vu d'activité
au niveau de ces de ses guérites le
président était mal protégés et ça se
savait le commando est entrée par la
grande porte en 1h de lourdes fusillade
seulement deux victimes le président et
son épouse
les autres victimes sont trois
mercenaires colombiens
l'un d'entre eux l'ex-militaire du
berner cappadoce heraldo dit à sa soeur
quelques temps dans sa mort qu'il
s'était arrivé trop tard la résidence la
personne qu'il devait protéger le
président était déjà mort les colombiens
ils étaient 26 ont été tués se sont
rendus ou ont été capturés alors qu'ils
tentaient de fuir
il n'avait aucun plan de sortie il était
simplement retourner chez eux
la principale agence qui les avait
recruté plusieurs mois auparavant
c'était une sécurité de miami avait-elle
aussi engager des assassins cinq
colombiens sont encore en cavale
le commanditaire du meurtre en tout cas
doit être riche et puissant on peut dire
ça à l'air d'un coup d'état par exemple
il est classique dans le cas d'un coup
d'état que les dirigeants qui sont en
place 10 à la population que nous avons
le contrôle de la city
ce discours la donne à penser enfin
situation sous contrôle avec ce vide au
sommet de l'état pour combien de temps
jean michel leprince sera du canada port
au prince